- So what were those first days like
'cause y'all were really young.
- (Howie) Yeah.
- Yeah I was 11 when I met these guys.
- You were 11!
- I was 14.
Yeah, I mean, back in the day,
we used to ride on,
basically like a Winnebago.
We were doing what they
called this ESM tour.
So we would go around to middle schools,
high schools, gymnasiums.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Auditoriums, and perform music
that nobody had ever heard.
We weren't signed yet.
- (Kevin) We did covers too.
- Oh yeah, Of course
- (A.J.) Covers and
- Covers.
- That's a hard play though to win over
like a high school crowd and like
- Totally.
- We have some great stories.
(all talking over one another)
Like even when you go to the school
and you're in something with the school
they're still mean like
it's like people are, yeah.
- We were in I think it was
somewhere on the east coast
and we're in this auditorium,
we're doing our stuff
and the entire sound system went out.
No mics, no nothing.
- (Brian) They pulled the
plug like. (blowing raspberry)
- So Brian is basically
trying to get everybody
to calm down and to stop
yelling and screaming.
And they got really quiet
and we just sang straight
acapella and we won them over.
- (Kelly) Oh, I love that story.
I was hoping it was going there.
(crowd cheering)
- (Nick) They were standing
up. They went crazy.
- (A.J.) Yeah.
- It was amazing.
- (Kelly) You know what though?
That's sometimes the better play.
Like sometimes it's because
we always do like big things.
I know people expect
like, big shows from you,
but it is those moments,
and I don't know if Laurie agrees,
but it's those moments
when you do something
like really like, I don't
know, broken down like that
that really just
showcases the real talent.
Like, you know, it's
kind of a cool moment.
- Totally.
- So that's probably why just
not everybody can do that.
- Well, it shows that
you're real, you know?
- (Kelly) Yeah, exactly.
- What we do is, is real, you know
all five of us singing together.
- (Kelly) Absolutely.
Just as you know, as a singer,
I mean that's what we came to do.
(all talking over each other)
- (Howie) Harmonies. We've
always, since day one,
we've always picked up
songs, Boys II Men, Shy,
Jodeci, Color Me Badd.
We we loved the doo wop,
even, groups back in the days.
We loved just picking
out all those harmonies.
And that's what we got
our signature sound was,
based around harmonies.
- (Kelly ) That's so awesome.
I'm glad you had that.
Cause I'm sure we all
had those moments when
things went like that.
And then we had moments
where they didn't go great.
You're like, am I talented?
And you have those moments.
You're like, should I quit?
And it's like, that was personally for me
when I saw U2 perform
Madison Square Garden.
And I was like, what am I doing?
I was like, I should probably quit.